[Applaudissements]
chez nous chez nous chez nous chez nous
c'est vraiment une
chance qu'on est fait
connaissance lorsqu'aux dernières
vacances tu es venu chez
nous traversant
l'Atlantique tu avais
classiqu des idées
romanties sur les gens de chez
nous car depuis bien longtemps aux yeux
des étrangers notre vieux continent n'a
pas beaucoup changé pe avec des façons
qui datent de toujours qu'en Europe les
garçons font au fill leur cou il
n'empêche que l'on
SIM et qu'on peut sans
problème se marier quand même
a comme on le fait chez
nous tu voudrais m'emmener
là-bas dans la ville qui t'a vu naître
où tout es grand trop grand crois-moi où
les murs n'en finissent pas moi je veux
bien te
suivre mais j'ai lu dans les
livres que le mieux pouris
vivre c'était encore chez nous
chez nous chez nous chez nous chez nous
je préfère aux grandes
cités la douceur d'un petit village où
sur la place les soirs
d'été on peut s'amuser et danser toutes
ces
différences dans nos deux
existence n'ont aucune
importance pour être heureux chez
nous dans la rue où
j'habite tout le monde
t'invite à devenir bien
vite une enfant de chez nous chez nous
chez nous chez nous chez nous chez nous
chez nous che n chez nous chez
[Musique]
nous